hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well fancy terms
where there's these things probably able
to put them into our own words some of
them some of them we don't like you know
for instance gratitude right you have to
have dr. Duchin what are other students
Fe yeah
broad strokes things that we can
identify he talks about you know the
dollars yeah reparation
yeah
well
what are you guys engaged in in this
class there's Duty that you're actually
fulfilling not to me that would be maybe
have a duty fidelity show up at certain
time I'm supposed to show up do you know
but a duty that you have to yourself
because you actually hold stuff to
support
we don't often think about it this way
but you actually have a duty he says
often and then he has these others like
beneficence and nice long hard to
remember one nun now Easons that sounds
very very legalistic doesn't so it's so
satisfied the duty of non malfeasance by
you know not pushing the person onto the
trolley that was that was on yelling we
don't talk about doing we have to do a
little bit of translation gratitude okay
that makes sense you guys don't have to
translate it hasn't that if anything
else
fidelity what does it mean to be
faithful what does it mean to exhibit
fidelity towards another person yeah
loyalty is a key part of it I think
that's probably the term read associated
with the most truthfulness which you
guys have often identified is a good
character trait would also fall under
fidelity he talks about promises if you
make a promise then you ought to keep it
that's part of being faithful I guess we
might consider that loyalty promise
keeping being reliable easy and certain
broader sense
what about reparation we usually think
of this like in terms of you know
political things that people are talking
about how to make reparations for this
for that he's talking about personal
things so what are our recreations in
personal life
we do anything wrong oh yeah what do you
need to do to have you've done something
wrong just brush it off and say yeah no
no no harm no foul
see you later better luck next time you
may go okay that's that's probably how
we put a making up for it or making it
right yeah all right
so and that could cover a lot of
different things right what are what are
typical hacks that we be out of
preparation what's the most basic act
that people oftentimes are satisfied the
apology right actually saying I'm sorry
I shouldn't have done that
I ended up hurting you or damaging your
property or your interest or letting you
down reparation is something we have to
do when we have not filled another group
generally I'm sorry I lied to you I'm
sorry I didn't follow through on my
obligation to do this at this time I was
supposed to give you a ride but I didn't
show up all sort of things you know
those of you things we'd apologize for
what else metaphors to do this have to
show for Ross it's very important that
you show rather than just merely feel a
sense of you know
yeah break somebody's window maybe buy
him a new window where you put it in for
them you know maybe there's some sort of
swap taking the ballgame be kind of
fitting all right
sometimes you can't actually fix the
thing and you can't pay for it so you
find something else nice that you could
do in return you know could be a gesture
sometimes a person might be bringing
flowers home because they they really
love their spouse sometimes they might
be sending flowers or bringing flowers
because they screwed up hey
and that gesture of setting flowers is
not just a way of saying I'm sorry it's
a way of trying to make them direct why
not actually yeah
adequate but you get the idea right
we'll come back to justice in let's
think about self-improvement why do you
have the beauty of self-improvement do
you actually feel that you have a duty
to not just you know take care of
yourself get yourself through square
meals a day a middle amount of exercise
keep yourself you know your body clean
so you don't get sick do you feel that
you actually have an obligation and not
an obligation of other people but an
obligation to yourself to take what it
is that you've been given and to make a
bit more of it and maybe in terms of
becoming a better person in terms of
what cross-balls virtue or maybe in
terms of intellectual development
learning I think most of you feel that
or else you wouldn't be here at Marist
dude who decided where your parents
expectations are put aside other
people's expectations of you put aside
the maybe the pressure that you get
their hands repressors you know that
sort of thing that you should you should
be this kind of students or all that do
you feel like you want to make something
of yourself
something more and once you you know
it's not to deny what you've done in the
past but is it okay just to sort of rest
on your laurels or should you be
continuously striving to be a little bit
more or is there at that point where you
can say that satisfied my obligations to
cultivate myself now that's the easy
street from from this point on once you
actually start doing self-improvement
you realize how much more you actually
- yeah I think we Ross is right now
notice it's not something proven in
terms I need to get myself more pleasure
we already have an instinct for that
right as a matter of fact sometimes you
have to struggle against that instinct
if we want to engage in self-improvement
and why do you even have a duty of
self-improvement again put aside
everybody else's expectations on you
know why
so you're worth something because you
are as a person
value and the only person who really has
control over whether you're going to
improve or not for the most part in this
point of your life is you you get to
decide the course of your life are you
going to improve merely in your major
which it by itself not knocking that's a
great thing right there that's
intellectual improvement you know
studying accounting is a great thing to
do you know you're acquiring a valuable
skill that other people will want to pay
you for and in which you can take
legitimate pride for having acquired you
acquire certain habits of mind business
requires me actually
you know becoming very close to business
but business and marketing or something
like that different principles at work
if you can wrap your head around those
and make that part of who you are you
haven't improved yourself you have
improved the stock into which you can
with which you you came into the world
the intellectual stock that you have at
your disposal and that's not just
valuable because somebody else wants to
pay you for it it's valuable because you
are yourself worth cultivating
you know it doesn't necessarily even
have to be I would say Ross probably
wouldn't talk about you know exercise
and sport as doesn't necessarily being a
self-improvement but I would see those
things
learning a new skill learning how to
cross-country ski that's a good thing
that's in some ways self-improvement
beneficence and non malfeasance
so beneficence is doing good in other
people do you have a duty to improve
other people's lives rush things that
you do do you feel that you have that
duty or you to say screw everybody else
so long as I don't hurt them
everything's okay let me put it to you
this way do you feel that there are some
people in your life who you have duties
to make happy to make their life better
maybe even in small ways maybe not you
know the United States citizens as a
whole or even your neighbors you know a
lot of us don't know our neighbors where
your dorm mates look like your family
and your friends do you feel yourself
you know under a kind of obligation or
duty to improve their their existence in
some way
doesn't that intrinsic to the very
notion of friendship there are the
people who you actually choose to make
can't be you know that's what you can
tell friends from frenemies right what a
friend of means to they aggravate each
other real friends
trying to make each other happy is it
possible for you to make other people
happy
we don't necessarily even know think
about walking around the campus there's
small things that you can do little
gestures
yeah courtesy I think you know some
people would want to say courtesy is
about infidelity this whole system of
rules and all that holding the door open
for somebody who's got a bunch of stuff
in their arms yeah it's a nice thing to
do and you're making it so you're right
it's a small thing but it contributes
it's not the same thing as like you know
writing have a check for million dollars
and mailing it off to a charity but this
it's something and we shouldn't overlook
the small things because again duty is
personal that's what we as individuals
can do that really matters now the
thesis means not doing harm that
nificent is doing good to somebody right
then a good now means bad so malfeasance
is doing harm to somebody and we not
only have a positive obligation to help
other people out to do to improve their
lives in some way and it could it could
be improving their lives with pleasure
it could be improving their lives
intellectually it could be improving
their lives by contributing to their
character development we also have an
obligation not to hurt them not to do
things that are going to screw things up
for for them I would say not
inconveniencing people unduly would fit
into this not
making it ourselves you know the center
of existence and thereby putting
everybody else out less you're certainly
not being cruel you know maybe the
obligation not to be cruel and don't be
sometimes every once in a while feel
like being cruel I know I do
still I'm stupid you know 42 years old I
should long gotten past that but you
know human beings we animals these dumb
instincts in us well you got to read
that stuff yep according to her of us
you know we have tendencies that we need
to keep our our eyes on one I put off
talking about yeah and which it we
should come back to is justice now Ross
says that justice is a little bit more
qualified than what we normally think
about when we talk about justice and
when we talk about justice in ordinary
of life quaint often we are talking
about things like paying people back
from what you know what harm they've
encountered or things like that Ross
says well that actually falls under
reparation that's that's not what he
means by justice or holding people to
the obligations they've made like they
about contracts if you make a contract
with the person you're obligated right
but a contract is really much more a
matter of fidelity so what is justice
what are other parts of justice how
about the way what you distribute things
so here's a really easy one to wrap your
head around how many of you when your
kids either in your own house or in
other houses saw some kids getting
favored none only a few again that seems
highly unlikely to me that all of your
parents were scrupulously fair nobody
ever got more affection more at
than the other kids maybe you don't want
to remember that maybe it's too painful
to think about or maybe you don't want
to remember because you're the one who
actually got over on it you don't want
to admit it but it happens that's enough
where else does that sort of thing
happen they happen to classrooms yeah
see that ever happened in not just you
know kindergarten and you know the
teachers patter something like that but
all the way through college you think
it's going to happen in the workplace
there it's going to be not just you know
affection and attention of the
opportunities and responsibilities now
if you're a just person you recognize
the obligation to apportion these things
fairly it doesn't necessarily mean
equally you know the person who has
greater capacities maybe should be given
more responsibilities right in the
workplace the person is a better
organizer you know a manager maybe
they're the ones who should be promoted
to the managerial positions but what
it's saying is everybody should get more
or less a proportionate or equal shot of
things if you're dealing with a
household going back to the favoritism
fact is it you know is it okay to to
love one kid and not to loan the other
two kids there's something really wrong
with that isn't there and that's not
just you know a failure in some of these
things that's a failure in terms of
justice we recognize that we have a
sense for this kind of thing yeah we
don't necessarily need a moral theory to
get that sense about it the other one we
didn't talk about is we already have a
worker grab - when should you be
grateful and might be grateful he
doesn't mean feel grateful he means act
gratefully what are things that you do
people that you're grateful yeah say
thank you that's a big one if you've
never to say thank you to people you're
going to be an isolated person I have
because everybody is helping you out all
the time whether you realize it there's
nobody who's a totally self-made person
and it's appropriate to show gratitude
for that what else we do anything else
do you guys do your ordinary life yeah
if it could be something quite different
than what they did it ends sometimes
it's proportion that somebody who's rich
you know who helped so somebody is poor
the poor person is not under an
obligation to like you know match
exactly what the rich person would do
that but if you if you can if you're
roughly the same then you should try to
help them out you know I don't think
about things as simple as you go to the
bar somebody buys you a drink we should
say thank you and then the next time
around right or you know with meals
that's what I don't like people who
don't pick up the checks you get to
notice more and more and more as you
start having business lunches and
dinners and things like that you should
you know if somebody helps you out you
should help them out in return you
should show that you're actually
grateful to that now all of these are
created by particular situations that
were like he says grant you what is the
situation it rests on a previous act by
another person service or benefit to
oneself that's a very you know for
theoretical way of putting duties of
justice they rest on the possible
distribution of pleasure or have
that's where the means to these
according to the merit of persons duties
of fidelity rest on one's promise or
implicit promise and if some of the
implicit promises would be you know when
we use communication verbal
communication we should generally tell
the truth we should generally say the
way the things are reparation rests on
previous wrongful acts by one's self
self-improvement rests on the fact that
you can improve your own case in terms
of virtue or intelligence non
malfeasance rests on the vulnerable the
vulnerability he doesn't use this term
but that's a good determinate thing
about the vulnerability that we have to
each other as beings not just physical
beings but also psychological beings
it's very easy to to harm another person
particularly if you set your mind to it
you know even people think that they
can't be harmed are pretty easy to harm
and then finally duties of beneficence
rest on the existence of other beings
whose existence we can make better and
all of these are situations in which we
find ourselves all the time right then
because of the network of relationships
within which you live and within which
you will live for the rest of your life
most likely and now notice you know we
don't feel these sorts of obligations to
things like our phones do we do weird if
we did being you know I mean if it's
suppose if you have the Siri remote Siri
we're fighting in the restaurant or
something like that but really who
should you be grateful to the designer
to create a personal gallery or you know
fix on somebody else some person right
these are these are duties that we have
towards ourselves and towards towards
other people and they're always within
certain contexts